hey guys Pete here I have another Game
of Thrones season 8 episode 1 bonus
video for you today the subject of this
video will be bran and what exactly is
going on with him I'm not the biggest of
bran fans I mean I like the actor and I
like certain parts of his story but some
people are super into bran
I get the attraction as he's cool you
know he's a lowborn guy he worked his
way up he sort of has that everyman hero
kind of thing going on plus he could
definitely be funny but sometimes I
think they overdo that part of the
character a bit so I like him but I'm
not in the super fan club since that's
the case I didn't pay much attention to
the idea of him being hired by Cersei
via Qyburn in the first episode of
season 8 honestly it didn't seem likely
that he would follow through with
killing his old friends and when I did
my episode 1 recap I just basically left
it there since then I had some comments
about this so I thought about this a
little bit more what stands out to me
the most about the scene with bran in
the short amount of time we spend in
King's Landing is that they included it
at all considering they condensed the
final season to 6 episodes based on
having the ending completely mapped out
we should expect that every scene is
essential for what they have in store
think about it they couldn't give us a
few more seconds to show Daenerys
internalize that the night King has
control of Masseria on one of her
children you know one of her dragon
couldn't had an extra minute to make
John discovering he was a dragon rider
more dramatic I mean think about it
insert any instance of something you
thought could have been a little bit
longer or anything else they could have
added the episode 1 and realized that
they gave us this scene with bran
instead this leads me to believe that
bran has an important role to play in
the end game of one of our main
characters and I think I know what it is
let's look into who that might be
first things first bran story has gone a
different direction in the books I won't
go into it too deeply because I want to
keep this short but bran hasn't actually
showed up in the books since he turned
down Tyrians offer to be his champion in
the trial by combat the updates we do
get about bran and what he's up to in
the books all come through Cersei he
ends up falling through with the
marriage
Lolly's that she set up and later she
becomes the lady a Stokeworth with brawn
as its Lord Cersei is the catalyst for
this as well and not because she's
trying to help bran get his castle in
fact in her paranoia which I discuss
more in the Circe video I made in my
problem series she starts to worry that
bran might still be in contact with or
under the control of Tyrion so she
launches a plan to have him killed this
backfires and in the end bran is in
Stokeworth with lolis this obviously
doesn't line up with what's happened in
the show so what I think is important
here is that sir she doesn't trust bran
because of his connection with Tyrion
and that does line up with what I said
in my episode 1 recap well it seems like
a bad choice to choose bran for this job
even if he doesn't follow through it
gets him away from Cersei if he kills
them then that's a bonus if he doesn't
at least he's not a potential threat for
the Queen inside King's Landing
Qyburn even points out that Tyrion and
Jaime aren't likely to survive their
northern adventures when he puts up to
her proposal so what did we see in the
actual scene bran is entertaining some
working girls and Qyburn interrupts he
tells bran that Jaime and Tyrion had
broken their promises and that the Queen
wants to rectify the situation bran
brings up that Cersei had also broken
her promise of giving him a wife in a
castle in Qyburn says that Jaime did
that not her he tells them that there's
gold waiting outside gives him the
crossbow the Tyrion used to kill Tywin
and implies that there would be more of
a reward if he actually follows through
I think the natural thing that we're
supposed to wonder about is if bran who
paints himself as a mercenary that will
do anything for the right price will go
through with killing them or not
I think that's unlikely based on what
we've seen and I think that bran does
have a sense of loyalty to both Tyrion
and Jaime on top of that he has to no
sir she doesn't have much of a chance to
hold on to her crown if Daenerys and her
dragons survived the battle in the know
I just don't think there's great
motivation for him to actually kill them
I think the fact that they included this
scene at all means that it's about
something else in season 5 episode 4
bran and Jaime travel to Dorne they have
a conversation about ways to die after
bran kills the snake that was getting
ready to buy Jaime while he was sleeping
when asked how he'd like to go Jaime
says in the arms of the woman I love now
I think most people expect that Jaime's
going to die before season 8 ends I know
I put him in my death predictions video
and I think the better question is with
whom Jaime will die rather than if he
will die since this episode aired back
in season 5 people have speculated that
it might be Brienne and I think this
bran scene seals the deal this is why I
know a lot of people are talking about
this trial Jaime's gonna have to go
through an episode - we've seen that in
the trailer for episode 2 but we've also
seen him fighting later on in the Battle
of Winterfell from the original trailer
so we know one way or another that trial
isn't very important as far as him being
found guilty or something along those
lines it's actually going to be a reveal
I think that bran will probably
intervene with evidence about what
really happened with the Mad King the
Jaime actually broke his oath and killed
him to protect the people and in a very
dramatic fashion that truth will find
the kid out there we know that brand has
seen this in his visions he's seen the
Mad King in his visions and we know that
Jamie has been haunted by this idea of
being known as the Kingslayer before
that happens I expect that Brienne will
make a passionate plea to everyone and
that Jaime will be moved by this
obviously there is love between Jaime
and Brienne but I think this moment will
make that clear for everyone to see then
when Bronn arrives he'll tell Jaime that
Cersei sent him there to kill him and
that will finally be when Jaime's love
for Cersei truly comes to an end since I
think he will die and I think it's
likely to be in brianne's
arms I think this could be bronze real
importance for the end of the story in
my thinking it has to be clear to Jaime
in his heart
and in his head who the woman he loves
is I think the crossbow could probably
play a part in this as well
of course they used that as a call back
in an episode with a crazy amount of
call back but you have to admit that it
seemed like a weird touch to include my
guess is that this is what bran would
use as proof of Circe's intention Jamie
left Cersei to go north
but he's loved her for as long as he can
remember more or less when he told bran
he would die in the arms of the woman he
loved he was obviously talking about
Cersei I think when he sees the crossbow
he'll have to confront the truth and
this will push him in brianne's
direction now admittedly I have been a
Jamie as the bound car fan for a long
time I've always thought it was fitting
in for both characters and yes I
understand they changed what Maggie said
in the show I actually made a video
about that a few years ago but I still
think that it's baked into Circe's
motivations what I mean is that I don't
think you can create an adaptation of
the character and the books without
having this be part of her motivation
whether it's explicitly stated or not
Cersei is a paranoid human being it's
what drives her and this idea of him
killing her has made it difficult to
decide when Jamie might actually go out
but as far as dying in brianne's arms is
concerned I guess it doesn't matter he
could die in the battle fighting by her
side or you could die later in King's
Landing but either way I think Brienne
will be involved with his end I also
have always liked the idea that Brienne
would fill out his pages in the white
book but who knows that the Kingsguard
or the white book will even exist when
all is said and done the important part
is that bran will explain what the Queen
is up to to Jaime and he will realize
that Brienne is actually the woman that
he loved I find this much more
satisfying than a bran character that is
facing a dilemma of killing his friends
or not but what do you think do you
think this was just included because we
have to have a good ending for bran he
has to decide to do the right thing or
not depending on which side you think
he'll end up on or do you think there
might be something to this idea that
he's really just a device to get Jaime
straightened up on who he's in love with
before he actually
bites the bullet let me know in the
comments I thought it was interesting
during the red carpet that a lot of the
media outlets were reporting about what
he said about his character he was
saying that the fans might not like him
so much anymore you know I'm
paraphrasing obviously and that the
filming wasn't that difficult for him
after seeing episode 1 it became clear
that he was saying that as it related to
the first episode not his entire
character arc for the season this
actually adds a little bit more fuel to
that fire because we're at the time I
thought maybe he was gonna stay in
King's Landing and maybe even be the one
who shoots down a dragon with the
scorpions he may have just been trying
to pull the wool over our eyes a little
bit in those interviews knowing that he
was gonna go north and hook up with
Jamie that's it for today I will be back
at the beginning of the week with my
normal schedule of videos I'll do a
recap a trailer breakdown and bonus
videos please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe and follow
along if you want to keep up with all of
what's going on and thanks for watching
I will talk to you soon